dad what's gonna happen if I put diesel  fuel in my car and hey Deb  dad I'm at a party and I need to punch  toilet dad what's a dipstick what the  hell is in the back of a toilet dan  which remote turns on my TV my light  went off how do I turn them back on I'm  trying to watch The Bachelorette well I  get electrocuted if I touch this circuit  breaker board light thank you Dad  how many plugs can I put an outlet  before it becomes dangerous can we sue  him for that  what's a Roth IRA can they sue us for  that I wasn't peeing in public anymore  money if the engine went off by itself  does that mean it's fixed yeah do we  have triple-a dad if I've never changed  my oil is that bad thing  hey Dad when did you know you wanted to  marry Bom  hey hey what's up what are you doing at  me I'm just talking to my dad we're  gonna be late okay hon hey Dad I gotta  go